well the bottom line is 17 games is
finally here
and chris the nfl has wanted this
for a long time a very long time well
over a decade
the commissioner used to make the case
for more regular season games
by attacking the quality of the
preseason with four games
and the response was like well you know
the preseason stinks i mean from his
his logic was sorry i misspoke now you
know four preseason games really not
indicative of the quality of nfl
football so
let's just move the the needle yeah
we've always had 20
always had 20. we've had 14 and six
until 1978.
six pre-season games can you imagine six
pre-season games no and then they just
moved it to 16 and four
so let's just move it to 18 and two that
was the argument
glossing over the fact that it's two
extra games that count
two extra games of high intensity two
extra games as you said yesterday where
the starters don't make a cameo
appearance and then stand on the
sidelines eating hot dogs for the rest
of the game right
these are real games so
they made that push chris just
at the time the nfl was forced by
congress to begin to take
brain trauma seriously there was too
much of an incongruity there you
couldn't reconcile
more regular season games with the nfl's
epiphany regarding health and safety
and it it fell apart but it didn't go
away
they still wanted it they as and they
still want
18. they won't say it right now yeah as
they do the victory lap on 17 but it's
going there
for now though it's 17. we knew this was
coming it wasn't news over the weekend
when espn tweeted it was expected to
happen
of course it was expected to happen it's
been expected to happen since the ink
dried on the cba from march of 2020
that gave the nfl the ability to do it
they've wanted it
for years and now chris they have it
yeah they have it
i mean listen as a fan it's one more
week of entertainment i love that
there's no doubt about it
you know you know my concerns as far as
yes
it is an extra game it's a bunch of
extra car crashes for certain guys
right and and it could be the difference
one extra game whatever it may be
and you know dictating your health how
you are
next year all those type of things but
either way i'm excited for it i am
i mean you know uh more football
more fun i'm i'm all for it in all ways
i really am
and to add the actu extra little wrinkle
to the schedule
that we think we're gonna hear or or
know about as far as you know the one
crossover
conference game and things like that um
it it all makes sense and i
always thought this was gonna happen you
know i'll say big phil
you know my dad he was the one that was
tweeting this out not long ago what was
that two years ago and the players were
like oh that's crazy we had him on the
show
we had him on the show right he said
they will agree he'll do it right and
here we are
you know so he was right about this one
but um
i i there's got to be i think more
conversation about a 18th game than
there was about a 17th game the players
got to realize what they're signing up
for here right now i don't know if
everybody
all the players realized what they voted
for and signed up
for for this extra game as you can
obviously tell
plenty of voted against it yes right
bunny voted against the cba in march of
2020
it didn't pass by a significant margin
and there was a period of time where
despite the endorsement of
nflpa executive director d smith the nfl
pa board of directors the board of
player reps and
they kind of went back and forth a
little bit but the final vote
ended up being very very close and
they all had their opportunity they all
had a voice and now the outcome of that
vote was new cba new cba includes 17
games but chris here's something
important to keep in mind right because
there's a faction of media that just
loves to criticize
everything nflpa leadership
does this imbalance is not a product
of nflpa leadership it's a reality
of the nflpa rank and file and it dates
back
to 1987. the last time the players
tried to strike well they did strike
they just didn't strike for very long
because the nfl went out and got
replacements and the game went on
and then players from the union started
to cross the picket line and it all fell
apart
if the players will not utilize
the nuclear option in labor relations
which
is accepting a work stoppage whether
it's one they initiate
via a strike or one they tolerate via a
lockout
and miss games lose checks if they won't
do it
and the owners will there's always going
to be an imbalance so
chris regard if let's go alternative
history here sure right if the union had
voted down
the cba in march of 2020 yeah what would
be
happening now is a lockout off-season
lockout
because the nfl was going to do whatever
it had to do to get to 17 games
and it would have locked the players out
for the entire offseason they would have
done a deal in early august because the
players don't want to miss game checks
and they would have agreed to 17 games
it's that simple yeah they were getting
17 games yeah the question was are we
doing it the easy way are we doing it
the hard way
yeah i mean i agreed i mean i i i mean
yes
this seemed like it was inevitable no
matter what the players are never going
to be able to strike
and do the things the hard way that's
not going to happen
the players it's one of the nflpa it's
one of the weakest unions in
in in all of you know in all professions
uh but it's but it's the nature of the
rank and file not leadership because the
buyers will not skip
i agree with you a hundred percent yeah
that that is
the problem it has nothing to do with
the leadership
it has to do with as a player you know
you only got a certain amount of years
to play football
and collect checks and yeah more times
than not
guys that are young don't want to
sacrifice this right hey here i am i'm
20 i'm only 24
once you know i only got a few years to
where i can really run 4-4
and and be at my highest you know
physical peak
ability so i don't want to strike or
miss out on that
let alone the amount of players who yeah
come from
nothing financially have no money
they're not willing to
sit out and make nothing when a lot of
the times
guys are supporting you know their moms
their dads their cousins their uncles
their brothers their sisters i mean i
know my father had to deal with some of
that
and his story's not nearly as bad as
some others so from that standpoint yeah
it'll never change
because i don't think the players will
ever draw that concrete line in the sand
and say no we're not coming to work for
a long enough time to to scare the
owners
you were what about but about like five
or six seven years
old remember about the stress in the
household during the strike in 87.
i remember like it was the year after
they won the super bowl
and i can remember i really do my dad
being bothered that
it was going to affect their run and
then i can sit there and remember
watching games with them going this is
so weird and look at this guy in a
giants uniform he looks like he was at
the bar yesterday
okay and then i also remember lawrence
taylor crossing over
if you remember you know and they're
playing the buffalo bills i could still
remember sitting in our family room with
my father watching lawrence taylor play
the buffalo bills and one of those
drunken guys that was in a
in a bar with beer and chips the night
before gave him a concussion
uh but it derailed the giants chance
that year to
have a repeat championship because they
didn't get good scab players in those
things but
uh it definitely added a little tension
in the house i can remember that year
and and that was the year that
washington had a plan right for the
replacements
and they ended up winning the super bowl
in part because they went 3-0
during that run helped position them for
the postseason what kind of tension
lingering animosity because
lawrence taylor crossed the picket line
did that linger once the players
returned and the strike ended i i don't
think so and i've had some conversations
with with dad about this stuff after
after it was all said and done i mean
one he was lawrence taylor
you know so nobody was gonna say a whole
lot to him as far as that was concerned
but like
two hey that's the one thing in the nfl
it's like to each his own
you know everybody's got their own
problems their own issues they own
things they got to deal with
and not everybody could sit there
financially and and not make money for
six or seven weeks or anything like that
so i don't remember animosity
uh in any way you know towards towards
lawrence more of like hey
he's got to do what he's got to do and
then that's that's that is what it is
and let me give you a quick example
because this is not an indictment
of professional football players i think
anyone in that situation would feel the
same way
in a normal factory and let's say you
make tires it's a tire factory
and there's a union and they go on
strike right
the factory shuts down well the tire
orders are still
there the work is still there they shut
down for a month
they go back and what do they do they
start picking up extra shifts they start
picking up
overtime they have an opportunity to
make back
a lot of the money that they lost during
the strike because the work
is still there right with football those
games go by
they're gone they're never coming back
right or or replacements come in
and and play the football games you're
never going to make that money again and
the paychecks are so much more
significant
than in a normal union setting you just
can't say no and you're throwing the
dynamic of i only got so many years to
play football
next year there's a whole new crop of
college players coming in that are going
to be competing for my job
i need to continue to develop as a
player i need to continue to take
advantage
of my ability while i still have it
that's why
the imbalance is there and frankly chris
i said this to peter king last night
when we were
working through this angle as to the
reality that 17 was coming whether the
union wanted it or not
i'm surprised the owners don't take more
advantage
of that imbalance than they do yeah i i
hear you they
they they could they could probably get
away with more
than what they do uh maybe they don't
want to seem like you know
total greedy pigs that way i don't know
but you're right the players are
powerless and mike i can just speak from
experience as far as in the locker room
and things like that
you know there's very few guys that
really give a damn
you know quite frankly in the locker
room about a lot of these issues
it's usually a small group of guys that
really care
and then they're trying to inform the
rest of the locker room and rally some
guys to understand you know the gravity
of the situation or any of that
but most the guys in the locker room are
just oh i don't give a damn oh the
player rep will figure it out whatever
blah blah blah
just tell me when i need to you know
play football but that that's that's a
big issue too and it goes into all the
things we've talked about and
and yes i don't think it's going to
change because i don't think the players
are going to wake up to these type of
things and all the circumstances we
brought up
they're certainly not going to change
with being young in the prime of your
career the financial issues all of that
so uh yeah the the owners the owners
have the ultimate power more power in
this sport than any other sport in our
country
and i'm with you it's going to 18 games
and it's going to
super bowl on presidents day weekend and
ultimately i mean i love that idea i
just want to make sure the players are
properly compensated
for for what they're going to go through
to to make all this happen and make all
this money for the nfl owners
even with 17 games assuming that 17
games lasts as long as 16 games did
which i will not
say right but but there naturally will
be presidents day weekend super bowl
on the years where the super bowl lands
on february 14 because that makes
the next day the third monday in
february which makes it
president's day so it will happen 2027
2038 2044 2049
2055. and i realized i turned 90 in
2055. so i'll slam around to see that
happen
but if if they go to 18 it happens in
all the other years
right and in those years i just
mentioned it would be president's day
weekend
before the super bowl i mean
okay but still i think that's the way to
do it
i mean yeah it won't lay out perfectly
every year
but the the the the just
the grandness of the super bowl and what
it's become for our country
and all of us want to have fun and drink
a
little bit and eat you know all the food
and yeah a lot right
i mean yes we all and nobody wants to
get to go to school or go to work or do
any of that
so that would be great to have that
monday off and just have it be a big
national holiday weekend
i mean come on what's more american
right now than you know
nfl football it's about as good as it
gets as far as that's concerned i don't
think there's a sport
that's more identified with our country
right now than nfl football that's for
sure so
i like all that i do are there any other
unintended
consequences or anything about this that
we're not thinking about with 17 games
the playoffs anything like that that you
think can arise from this situation
well because it creates an imbalance in
home in a way the smart thing the easy
thing for the nfl to do and this is what
pointed to that extra game being an
inter-conference game right which
actually which actually builds a little
more equity into the schedule because
it's another game where
based on how you finished in your
division and currently there's only two
games on the schedule
that are driven by where you finished in
the division the year before
now there'll be a third game that your
opponent
finished in the same spot you did and
that's how the formula
applies and it's all afc teams at home
this year in those inner conference
games
all nfc teams on the road so there won't
be a situation where
some teams in a conference have nine
home games some have eight
and when you've got seven playoff spots
up for grab three wild cards it doesn't
matter what division you're in
it's fair and it's proper to have all of
the teams
yeah in one conference have the same
number of home games now
some of those home games will become
international games but they were anyway
they were anyway so you're either having
seven home games
or or eight home games now it's gonna be
eight home games or nine home games true
home games
in whichever conference you're in and i
think you know obviously this is a path
to having more neutral site or
international games and ideally
all of those extra games would end up
being
played somewhere other than the home
team
stadium you've got 16 games now you've
got more inventory
so what are they thinking or like in
england or wherever they're going to try
to make all those type of games and an
international flavor
something like that you think that's
where they're headed with this too to
where that extra game is going to be
mexico whatever like you're saying do
you think there's a chance or a
possibility of that
i saw something where starting at some
point all teams in one division
will have an international home game so
you don't have
that that hey you know one of the teams
is only playing
eight home games this year the others
all get nine
the extra they'll all get they'll all
get
uh up an international neutral site home
game
to balance that out but you know you got
to find enough
venues you got to be ready 16 games
elsewhere right and it's you could put
all of them in london
and london's not ready for 16. the most
london's ever going to have is eight
that's what simulates having a team
right right we got eight home games just
like anyone else we just see different
different teams every week instead of
the same team which i think would
actually be that'd be kind of that i'd
kind of like that yeah if i'm in london
right
because then you don't get saddled with
some crap team that you have to go see
everyone not to become a vikings fan or
something like that
exactly exactly or the giants since 2011
but uh that's because chris is a giants
fan sorry other giants fans i had to get
back to him
but um it just gives them something to
work with but you know that's not the
driving force for this creating
inventory for international games
isn't what pushed this i know what made
this go over the top
and they wanted it even before the
supreme court opened the floodgates for
legalized gambling
but this is all about the push for more
inventory
we need more games that people can wager
on either
before the game starts or during the
game we've talked about the play-by-play
opportunities to cast bets on your cell
phone device because you're getting
real-time pictures every play
every prop everything every drive a
dollar here a dollar there it's more and
more and more and more and more money
for the nfl they want to increase
inventory that's why they're going to
want to go to 18. yeah
and chris the next frontier is to add
teams
i'm telling you that's what's going to
happen that's the question
after the monday or tuesday or wednesday
or whatever day of the week we're
talking about 18 games is finally here
the spin it forward will be when will
there be 34 teams when will be
there be 36 teams because they're going
to keep looking for ways to have more
games
and that's a better way to have more
games because it doesn't put more stress
and strain on the bodies of any one
group of players
because it's just more teams playing the
the already existing number of games
sure sure i i mean i hear you there i
mean
i i guess i i worry hey injuries
all of those type of things you know
will the players be fairly compensated
through that
for two extra games i mean those are the
things i worry about i i don't know
um i had oh but here's they're already
they're already i know they're already
sharing the pie
the bigger the pie the more they get and
then it all so it doesn't really matter
salary cap but here's the right all
right so here they're getting they're
getting their fair share no matter what
however much money the nfl makes i know
see but but to me it should be
like a little and then some because
again
it's the risk has gone up significantly
more for one side as compared to the
other that's where
i just that's where i don't think it
should just be apples to apples
again this is going to end people's
careers a little shorter especially when
we get to the 18
game thing that it is it's going to
affect careers which is going to affect
401ks and all of those type of things as
well
but either way that's a different
conversation for a different moment
the other thing too is at what point do
we talk about
an extra bye week or something like that
too
you know i i remember a time right where
was that was that 93 or 92 one of those
93 it was the year right where they did
the double bye week right
and to me that's got to be something
that probably if you're going to ask
teams to play
18 games or 17 games and everything like
that and their regular season football
games
that yeah another another week of rest
for the players is certainly something
that
i would think gets talked about here at
some point
i i remember july of 2019
when for whatever reason and i think the
reason was the nfl and the nflpa were
approaching the commencement of
negotiations that culminated
in the cba in march of 2020. this
talk came up out of nowhere for 18 games
18 games they're going to be 18 games
will it be 18 games
and mark murphy the packers ceo spoke
at the packers annual shareholders
meeting
and he said he's opposed to 18 but
he was in favor of 17 and i actually got
him on the phone because he did a
session with reporters i was at the
beach i was able to get him on the phone
he was on the record and he talked about
17
and that was the first time that 17
really emerged as the viable compromise
to 18.
and i asked him at the time what about
two bye weeks and he said the networks
don't want two bye weeks because what
happens with two bye weeks
when you start giving teams off two
weekends
you're diluting the product you're
diluting
the weekends you've got fewer games
available but you know what chris
here's here's the attraction to having
fewer games available
as we get to this moment where
each game can be its own event yeah each
game is an opportunity to bet for three
hours
and and that's coming i've said this
we've talked about it the
the pandemic creating these extra
windows by necessity
you want as many i believe eventually
for the nfl as many stand-alone games as
you can so if you can take
what would be 19 weekends with 18 games
yeah and make it 20 weekends on the
regular season right
with 18 games that's more opportunities
to slow it down
carve out windows and not have seven
eight nine games being played at once
not have more than two or three games
being played
at once so that may change that attitude
and it's it's a a justifiable attitude
by the networks
we don't want the product to be diluted
with two bye weeks
maybe you do want it to be deluded
because it doesn't matter at that point
whether it's the cowboys or pick a team
no one wants to watch at any given time
it's just football on tv and we're
engaged and we're excited
because there's all these extra gaming
opportunities that pop up around it no i
mean i i i get that i mean
again i think we got a little taste of
that this year with coven 19 and
everything being spread out
i mean it yeah okay sundays might have
not been as
you know crazy as what we're used to but
i thought
you know i i think you agree with this
the quality of being able to
sit down and watch the game and get
emotionally invested got better this
year because the games were
were more spread out because there
wasn't always like
you know eight games at one pm on sunday
afternoon
you know there was days where you went
wow there's only five games here
six games this is pretty good i can
manage sunday afternoon
and i'm excited for sunday night monday
night
oh tuesday night football this year and
that type of stuff double header monday
night
i mean i would think that there's yes
some value into that and especially to
like what you keep saying with the the
you know legal gamble eyes or
legalized gambling i almost said it i
said in my own thing even though i
thought about it
that that just makes too much sense even
to me as a guy who doesn't gamble i want
to sit there and
and i i would understand the thought of
man this is awesome let me bet on this
play this game and i'm all in on one
game to get a feel for it and
you know you feel more invested in it
that way one of the most stressful
frustrating days of the year for me
comes the first sunday of the nfl season
when you've been waiting and waiting and
waiting for football to come back
and then at one o'clock eastern on that
sunday
it's chaos yeah with all those games
starting at the same time it's like man
i'd really like to just watch that game
what's going on in this game i'd really
like to just watch this game
well there's a game down here i'd really
like to watch that game
and i think that's where it's moving
more windows on sunday
early morning i hope the london game i
love that four windows on sunday two on
monday
tuesday wednesday maybe two on thursday
at some point
i'm telling you this is where it's going
saturday and sunday or friday and
saturday excuse me are currently the
only days that are off limits because of
the broadcast and i trust exemption i
won't go down that rabbit hole the
bottom line is they can't do friday and
saturday
they should labor day weekend in
mid-december i i feel like that
that will be that will be changing
at some point i think that will be
changing that i i hope
not i hope they don't go too far with
that you know again i want games every
day of the week but
you know again they're just said it you
just said it i know
games every day of the week i do but
there's sense in having
you know friday and saturday there
there's games too it's just okay it's
not nfl games
you know heat confirms friday and
saturday are days of the week yeah they
are they are days of the week but they
should be for high school and college
football
that's still really important and it's
really important to the nfl too
that's the other thing i mean the nfl
they're they're doing their damnedest to
get young kids play 60 do
all that type of stuff to get out there
and play football
we know there's still a stigma out there
as far as parents and the fear of that
so i don't think they should squash you
know community
little league friday saturday football
by you know basically trumping it with
you know the big show the nfl
on there during those times that to me
would be wrong that way i mean i i don't
want to see that let college and
high school have their time in the light
what about a friday afternoon game now
that the world has changed and so many
people are working at home what about a
one o'clock
eastern friday afternoon game so the pro
game is
done in time for all the high school
kids to pack up their gear and go play
their game of course they're in school
but uh you know
they're not in the 18 to 49 right uh
demographic group and they're not
they're not gambling they're not
gamblizing so they can miss the game
they can watch it later but uh
you know i i look between gambling
the way society has changed as a result
of the pandemic with so many people
working at home
all bets are off at this point and a new
universe of opportunity has been
unlocked
17 games is just the start
it's going to become more creative
more aggressive and the owners will
eventually
get what they want it took about a
decade they got what they wanted via the
expansion of the regular season
as more and more money flows through the
the
the gates thanks to gambling they're
going to want more
and they're going to get more they're
going to get more they're going to get
18.
that they're going to get two by ones if
they want to buy they're going to get
more teams if they want more teams
i'm telling you that the gambling
revenue and it's
it's ironic and we are using that word
correctly here because
for decades the nfl treated
gambling like the bubonic plague and now
that it's legal
and now that it's waking up slowly but
surely to all the different ways it can
make
money this billion dollar business
becomes a trillion dollar business
in time that's what they're looking at
yeah i mean
yes you're exactly right i mean it's all
about you know
the the dollars that that i get now
you know what i'd be interested to know
too you know and maybe you know this
just because this is something i didn't
look up i really didn't think about it
kind of just came to me organically a
little bit
but you know there's all this talk about
player safety player safety player
safety
have the numbers shown over the last two
years that player safety has improved
you know i i want to say yes i but i
can't remember like off the top of my
head right now
because i wonder if that's something
that was looked at here throughout this
process
for the owners to go okay wait look
injury rates are down
player safety we've helped it out now's
the time to inject you know 17 games
let's get to 17 and then we'll evaluate
again
and see if injury rate increases the
concussions increase
all those type of things and maybe
that's when they push for that 18th game
but i would imagine that that had
something to do with this conversation
too the fact that there's been so much
talk about that
it would have been insensitive to try to
do the 17th game four or five years ago
and i want to say i feel like the
numbers have come down which
can easily make the owners justify this
move you know even better
this is a comment from roger goodell
from july of 2019
right 18 pivoted to 17. he was asked by
cnbc about the push for 18 games
and here's the question there seems like
one of the sticking points as you're
pushed to 18 games how do you address
concerns about player injuries as well
as the question about
whether there could be just too much
football and he said we always talk
about how do we
restructure our season is it the right
structure with 16 regular season games
and four preseason games should we look
at expanding the playoffs these are
discussions we're having with the union
i think the steps we've made to make our
game safer
and better have worked tremendously well
in collaboration with our players
but also in changing rules and equipment
we had a 30
reduction in concussions last year 2018
and i think we can use that same model
to reduce injuries
for lower body right so look and and
that
we've seen it every year there's this
push make the game safer make the game
safer make the game
safer and it's from a humanitarian
standpoint
that's good because for too many years
player
health and safety it wasn't even an
afterthought it wasn't on the radar
screen not at all
but now that the path to getting more
inventory
is be obsessive about health and safety
the league has an incentive to do it and
it's done it
and that makes it easier to say
we want more because we think the game
is safer and really chris
those old games from when your dad
played on the green cement
and and they beat the crap out of each
other go to youtube there's plenty of
of nfl officially licensed old games on
there from the 80s and the 90s the level
of brutality is shocking
in comparison to today's game so 16
games in that environment
versus 17 or 18 in this environment
i think it's a night and day difference
and i i'm just i look i understand
the issues that arise in the wear and
tear but the wear and tear
now is dramatically less
on an average play basis than it was
back in the 80s and 90s when they were
killing each other no no doubt the game
was definitely not as brutal i mean
when you watch those games like you said
i mean of course there's you know
the the defensive the defensive lineman
can drive the quarterbacks into the
ground
you can hit them in the head you know
you know anything over the middle goes
throwing the football oh but you took
his head off up no big deal
it's uh he it was legal taking his head
off is legal in this day and age it was
a totally different game but the nfl has
to continue on this path
if they want to do 18 games and add more
teams like you're talking about
and that makes more players which of
course can water things down a little
bit
they got to stay on top of you know
injury rates and player health and all
that too
because if you do get to 34 teams and
now teams are a little bit more spread
thin with high-end talent and things
like that
you know that that could hurt the
product so the nfl's done everything
right and i really applaud them
and i love what they're doing with kids
and the community and everything like
that
it's going in the right direction i just
want to make sure they stay on top of
that and of course like i talk about
just fairly compensate the players
who are taking the ultimate risk here by
getting in all these more car crashes
now
a couple of other things before we take
a break on this 17 game season starting
in 2022
all teams will play host
to an international game at least once
every eight years
and nfl is likely to play games in
germany and south
africa or south america excuse me not
south africa that would be
that would be something from america
somewhat closer
than south africa uh and also also as it
relates to
us nbc you know there was a flip-flop of
super bowls with
cbs so that nbc could once again
have this mega february super bowl
winner olympics in the same month
with the super bowl being pushed back
because the season has expanded
the super bowl lands on the middle
sunday
of the winter olympics which is going to
create awesome some hectic times and
it's going to be awesome and nbc's
excited about it because
you spent the whole first week of the
olympics promoting the super bowl
you spend the super bowl promoting the
whole second week
of the olympics it's the perfect fulcrum
of the winter olympics to have the super
bowl right there so that will happen
february 13 smack dab in the middle
of the winter olympics in beijing the
super bowl
in l.a and we will be there for that and
that will be
awesome the first super bowl to cap the
17 game
seas hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports